All right. Hey, what's
going on? His bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcasts and
I am just checking in on you.
I didn't yell this time.
I did yell at this time because I'm
sitting across from a man who is currently
setting the Guinness Book of World
Records for podcasting in a day,
promoting his new show on Netflix.
Stand up in a way for episodes,
uh, debuting Christmas
Eve. Ladies and gentlemen,
what are the greatest debt of
comedians and say the middle life.
Please welcome Mister Brian Regan
Bell. How are you man? I'm excellent.
How are you doing? You look like
you've already to glaze over here.
You're on the whole media
tour, right? Did they get you?
Did you do some morning TV?
Did you do have that crap and morning TV?
I am not comfortable
with those morning shows.
I tend to love doing these with other
comedians. Oh, okay, good, good.
You know when it's, when it's
not another comedian, it's, I'm,
I am so horrible at them.
Find your funny Brian. Oh boy.
It's what can people expect from
your show? That's the moment,
like if I'm doing a phone interview, like
a radio and phone, radio interviewer,
well as soon as they say,
what can people expect people for
people who aren't familiar with you,
what can they expect from your show?
I know right away they're not familiar
with the person asked me the question.
Yes.
And I just want to hang up.
Like I just want to get a few
to be over at that moment.
It's your show going to be the exact
same thing I just watched on television.
Yeah, that's another one. Did
you write any new material?
Now it's going to be exact same shit.
See, after I finally got a special,
I then wanted to ruin it by boring
people by doing the exact same stuff. Uh,
Brian in this company asked you all
hacky questions in this current comedy
climate,
how do you find the altitude to fly
at with your current presentation of,
of satire? I'm going to
fucking cry. It's a, it's a,
it's an insane world. It's in the
same world right now. But um, anyways,
tell me about your show.
It's a hybrid half stand up,
half sketch.
A lot of the older bits that I used to
do years ago when I do my shows around
the country,
people at the end of my show sometimes
like to hear some of the older stuff and
I'm like, well what can I do? Maybe I
could do something with this. So I'm just,
you get,
you're like that good that you have
like classic jokes that's harder than a
classic song. Yeah. I'm not going
to use that word on myself, but, uh,
it's nice of you to say that, but uh,
you know, so I'm like lay it on thick.
The Johnny Cash.
Yeah.
Well it feels good that people
still like to, you know,
hear some of these routines and I thought,
well,
maybe I can do something with them,
but I don't want to just do the standup.
I mean, people don't know that. So I
thought maybe if I do like a standup bit,
and then that segues into some sketch
or something like that. And, uh,
Jerry Seinfeld got involved.
Oh, here you go. Um,
he was the one who reached out and he's
always been cool with me and said that
he wanted to help spearhead
me having a show. I mean,
what better phone call is that? It's an
a life that's a big phone call. You know,
like, like you're, you're on the
phone going, look at these goosebumps.
I got goosebumps. Yeah. You know,
it's funny when you said this when you
were describing your show is I, that's,
he's the first person I thought I was
like, Jerry would like to show. He was so,
you know, was cool. He said that he
had this idea, he didn't have the idea.
He said he wanted me to have a show.
He said,
let's get together sometime and see if we
can talk about this. And I was like, go,
you know, of course, you know, and um, he
was performing in Las Vegas where I live,
so I went to go meet him at his
sweet.
They have sweets and hotels that are like,
that I didn't know were possible,
like piano and a segues to take it from.
What
kind of room is this? You know,
so I go, we go meet and we chat.
And he said, yeah, you know,
he thought that I was one of the
comedians that have, should have a show,
which was just a huge, huge honor even
hearing that. And he said, well, you know,
maybe we'll get together and talk about
it sometime soon. And I said, well,
I have an idea. And he goes, okay. And I,
I know he likes coffee, right? So I said,
do you mind if we order some coffee?
And we chat about it.
So called room service.
They brought up a pot of coffee. I
pitched it to him in about three minutes,
you know, and he goes, I
like it, let's do it. And um,
I got emotional. I swear
to God, I started like,
I got a tear in my eye because it
show business doesn't work like that.
Say we had his shell
business does. Yes, exactly.
I knew when he said,
yeah, yeah, let's do it.
And then you do it. And
I knew it was happening. I mean, I'm
on belittling all the work he does,
but like he has like the,
uh, whatever that is. Like,
he knows when an idea is good and
then he goes, let's just do it.
And then he does it. He does it way
he wants to do it. Everybody responds.
And then,
uh,
and I knew back the bank
truck up exactly that.
The money part as isn't
even that important to me,
you know, I mean right now,
but just his cloud agent
just slapped his forehead.
It goes renegotiations wait,
are they going to play this
wait is still be down to
earth crying some point.
Would you be a little bit of a diva?
Yeah. But I knew when he said he wanted
to do it, that it was going to happen.
Right. Who's going to
say no to him? You know?
And I knew that he's the one
shepherding this. So anyway,
it was like really that uh,
that uh, he's supporting
this. Yeah, I would say,
I would say that would be a, uh, if
you're going to go in with anybody,
that would probably be
something he did for them.
How long does it take
you to shoot an episode?
I'm fascinated with this aspect of it.
Of the Wendy,
you get to go home aspect of showbusiness.
Well there was a lot of writers' meetings,
you know,
a a bunch of weeks of that, you know,
just coming up with the sketches.
A lot of the sketch ideas
I had already had. Um,
and then we shot the sketches also.
Not everyone of them is based
on one of your older bits.
It's just some of them are and
some of them are newer ideas.
None of the sketches are stand up done
as a sketch. I didn't want to do that.
Stand up. I love stand up and
stand up. Should be stand up.
So do the one where you wanted to do the
cattle prod and the person who's just
standing where they're supposed
to be walking in the airport.
It was one of my favorites. I like to see
somebody, maybe that one, maybe that one,
I'll do it.
But I wanted to stand up to be stand
up and then I wanted some type of
transition into a sketch.
Sometimes it's a natural lead in,
sometimes you have to kind
of like horseshoe it, you
know what I mean? And um,
but that was part of the fun too,
is like manufacturing
these segues into sketches.
So we shot all the sketches and then we
shot all four episodes in two nights in
front of a live audience
where we would throw,
I do stand up and then throw to the
schedules effect. Yeah. So in theory,
if you got 10 episodes,
you could be done by Wednesday for
foreign to do a half day on Wednesday like
they have as a PTA meeting and then
you're done. Yeah, it was cool.
It was cool. And then, you know, the
final night, you know, it was, uh,
happened to be my birthday and had a
big birthday celebration after that.
So it was like a nice, uh, it was a
cool experience. That's awesome. Well,
my next, next time I do a TV show, I don't
think I'm going to do animation again.
I tried. Donna was being so smart. I
love my show. I love doing the show,
but it's just like there's
always, you know, all, you know,
every gay shut the episode in
three days. I'm like, Jesus
takes us a fucking year.
You get this thing done. Um,
so any who, some of the cast
members, anybody I know,
I didn't want a normal cast.
I cast pur sketch, you know,
so it isn't like there's a from Isis,
how against the grain dejected
Dick did you cast here? I want it.
Like if it was a particular sketch where
you had three characters we would cast
for that particular episode or
that particular sketch. You know,
I didn't want like a,
like a mad TV or uh, oh,
you don't want to know kind of thing.
People know whoever services the thing,
you know. Okay. And uh, so
there's some obscure people,
but uh, they were all great.
Soon did not be obscure when this
thing debuts, like I said earlier,
four episodes on Netflix,
Christmas Eve. Um,
so you're a Florida Guy, right? Yeah. Um,
what can people expect from a Florida
guy with a sketch show? Sorry,
I just love those questions.
Oh, what do you think about
occurred? Prevalent. Is that crazy?
You get a Lotta let him
material that event. Yeah.
So heat in a, uh, a social situation.
When you meet somebody who just finds
out you're a comedian and like every
single thing that said
they have to throw in.
I bet this going to
end up in your routine.
You should talk about this.
You know,
somebody has a chip and they put some,
you know,
some guacamole on it and
it falls on a table. Okay.
I bet that's going to end up in your
act in front of you in the buffet line.
Don't put this in your APP. Yeah,
usually try to avoid bombing.
My job is to entertain, I mean I might
put this in the act there. Right, right.
That's this because now we are,
we're actually, they're actually,
we're putting it in the act. You
described the Guac falling off the chair.
Do you know what I want more of?
I want it
more celebrities, uh, celebrities.
If I can say the word telling me
about their political opinions,
I can't get enough of it.
You know,
cause I'm very unsure on
what I think about the world,
in which way I'm going to vote.
And then all of a sudden the f the
six lead on a sitcom, you know,
informs me about fitting or something.
And I'm like, oh, okay. That's,
that's how, that's how I need to think
about that. I want to see the flip.
I want to see in an og duration ceremony
for a congressman and during his
swearing in, he says, who should
have one for wardrobe design
in a movie? You know, criticized,
criticized the wardrobe
winners, you know, um,
which of course is absurd, but I
know it's a weird, it's a weird time.
And you know, I, I've never felt,
uh, I don't feel old, you know,
I fill out, I just feel like,
uh, it started with the music.
I didn't know what
people were listening to.
I didn't know where the popular bands was.
And then I started to not know who
the players were playing sports.
And now it's like a, yeah,
I don't know the words,
you know, I don't, I don't know. No other
words that I'm not that bad. I just,
I just, I, I, uh, I don't
agree with it. When, uh,
the academy awards come
out, the, it used to be,
I had seen all of the movies that are up
for best picture than it was like, oh,
I didn't see that one. Then it was
like, oh, I saw a couple of them.
Right.
And then it got,
now it's gone to the point where
I've never even heard of any of them.
Yeah. I've never even heard of them.
Yeah. I haven't even heard of him. Well,
now there's so much stuff to watch you
or they just got rid of another Oscar
host.
Yeah.
Evidently he tripped somebody in like
outdoor recess it like in 1983. Oh,
that was it. And there was some
sort of getting me in kindergarten.
Kindergarten thing. Yeah.
Yeah. On a final plan.
I don't blame him because
that was a mistake.
That was a mistake that
he made in his past. Yeah.
And tripping is never to be a times you
apologize for it. It's never cool. No,
I think all,
I think all mistakes in life should
disqualify everyone from any future
endeavors. If your acumen. Yes, yes.
No mistake should be allowed for in,
in the human condition.
Perfect people. Perfect. People should
host award shows. Perfect. People should,
when Heisman trophies, they should uh, um,
host award shows the savvy people
like us. Perfect. People like us.
So I want to add for younger kids now
because so much of this shit is like on
video and just some of the,
again, they're going to be fun.
I think the amount of the population
that won't be able to run for any sort of
office, I just wonder, you know,
there's always pendulums and everything
and right now the pendulum is over.
Two people want to, is it pendulum?
A pendulum? You might be right.
I don't know anybody. Geez.
Aaron Pendulum Pendulum.
Oh, I'm getting a nod that I'm
right. Look at that. Look at that.
But once pendulum, well
it's a angel. You know what?
The Florida schools pendulum well there
did you go to Ponce De Leon High School?
I went to pendulum high school.
I went to fend the Hi
Fountain of Youth Junior high.
I went to Christopher Columbus high
school coach should talk about, you know,
politically incorrect in today's world.
You know, another guy who stand where,
where like where all of that new evidence
came. If he did all of that shit,
what did he write it all down?
He tweeted it a toy they went back to,
is this tweet to do you got to do a
sketch about that case on the lumber?
Say go back in, hey, you know, it
was on the Santa Maria, you know,
and it's a lot of time going from Spain
or wherever they left from over to the
new world. So we would just sit
back in his cabin and tweet. Uh,
yeah. Uncredible Wifi is,
he went across the ocean.
Um, so anyway, I, yeah, I do. I
went to a Columbus high school.
I forget the point of, I
forget the question and what
my answer is. I don't know,
but I'm enjoying it.
All right,
good talk anytime you can talk about
Columbus Tweeten when he should be captain
on the Santa Maria.
Uh,
that's actually a great premise.
Like how quickly would Hitler get kicked
off at Twitter? The second you got on
Hitler,
you said Queer.
You can't say that. That's a
great sketch. All these people,
and then you've got to have like, you
know, Mother Teresa when she was young,
something she did. I don't know.
Who knows? Uh, anyways, what's your,
are you still see you a college football
guy? What was your deal? I played,
I played college ball. That's what
it was. Um, a small division three.
So, um, it was sorta like a school,
Heidelberg College in Tiffin, Ohio.
Loved my years there. Just,
you know, Midwestern school,
just like if you were to film a
movie and a Midwestern campus,
this is the perfect place. You
know, just a thousand students.
Everybody knew each other and uh,
fix your supreme court justices either.
Okay. Yeah. Right, right.
It was a perfect tablet.
Wasn't underneath what was happening.
So I played football there. Love that.
I actually tried out for
a semipro football team.
When did it happen in those
leaks, by the way? The a F A,
I'm sure you've heard of that.
No,
nobody has the American
Football Association. Okay.
And uh, they had a, they
were forming this new league,
so there was a team going to form in
Orlando called the Orlando Americans.
They were going to play in
the Tangerine Bowl. Nice.
Have Buddy of mine went up and tried
out and they invited him to camp.
He's a quarterback. He played at
Notre Dame and he said, Reagan,
you should go up there
and try out as a receiver.
I played receiver in college and I'm
like, Guy, I was out of shape, you know,
it was that a year and a half
after college because no, the,
the talent up there is the
kind that you could fit in.
So I went up and try it out of this big
mass tryout and he invited me to camp.
Wow.
They invited me to camp.
They brought a nine receivers in the camp.
But when,
then we had to try out from there.
They were only going to keep three
receivers. They had like a skeletal squad,
like two starters in one backup,
you know, and they cut down to five.
I was one of the five, I was one of the
five left. Nice. And then they, uh, I had,
I did a post corner pattern
and through my hip out and um,
I don't think I would've made it
anyway, but they cut me. Cut me.
I'm just picturing you running in your,
your standup crouch.
Like that's why you threw your hip up.
What year was that?
How will I was to hold?
Are you
um, well I was like 20. No.
Yeah, it was probably 20 to 22.
I already too out of shape.
Yeah.
Well if it is, no, no, I was, I meant that
as like a compliment to athletes item.
I think I had a cousin, uh, played
a little semipro football. Um,
does those leaks still exist?
Is that an actually an actual way into,
I feel like it's the CFL or you
walk on and you know, that's it.
Like as far as getting into the after
college to try and get into the NFL,
I figured either going to stand out at
the CFL and even then that's a long shot
or you just try to get a
walk on right after college.
Well,
I,
I had no aspirations of
making it in the NFL zero,
you know,
like,
but the fact that my buddy thought I
could make this one team, I thought,
well this could be a good experience
for a year or two if I could get on the
team. And uh, no that, that particular
league doesn't exist anymore.
So what exactly did you do to your
hip? I did a post corner pattern. Yeah.
You know, you see 45 degree
angle and then cut back out.
I had these hip pads that were too
tight and I just remember feeling like a
sprawling, oh no. And I have no idea.
Like I didn't have money to go to
a doctor or anything like that.
I just couldn't walk. Kind of hard
to make a team when you can't walk.
So
waiting for that feeling to go away.
And then you just thought it still hasn't
gone away. Continued on with your life.
Yeah. It still hurts. It still
hurts. My knee hurts from football,
you know? Uh, when I was in college,
I had a knee thing and they would shoot
me up with cortisone for the games
because we had to keep
this ONH streak going.
Oh yeah.
You know what I mean? And they would
shoot bit with cortisone. It was,
it was amazing because,
uh,
the pain was so intense when
they didn't shoot me up.
Like I could barely walk and then they
would shoot me up before the games and
I'm going to field running
around like a deer, you know,
like I felt like Bambi like,
but while I'm running,
I'm practically hearing crunch,
crunch, crunch, crunch, crunch, crunch.
It's just twisted my knee up,
you know? And I finally quit.
I quit college because of the knee.
I was worried that I was going
to do permanent damage to it.
Did you want me to still hurts it a little
bit here and there, but uh, yeah. Yeah.
He, one of those weather guys,
Nice. Starts acting up. You're like,
this is going to be a twist.
That's my hip. It's going
to be a cold front. Um,
I can tell asteroids when an asteroid is
coming. Oh really? That's interesting.
Yeah. Um, is that your hip or your knee?
My hip is like if there's an
incoming asteroid and mine,
my knee lets me know if there's an
earthquake coming on. Wired bizarre.
You know what I think
here at all things comedy,
we could cut a side deal with
the weather channel. You know,
let's cut over to Regan,
anything hurting the Regan report
and here we go. Oh, oh, oh
I feel a magnitude six coming on.
You know,
I really resent to channels that I
used to actually enjoy was the weather
channel. I actually used to like watching
it and for some stupid reason enter the
discovery channel and both of them, you
know, I dunno. I Dunno what they did.
I don't like how the,
you know,
the discovery channel further like
makes sharks look out like they're just
inherently mean things, you know,
with all this shit going. Like,
now we sit there and then whenever you
watch, you know something on sharks,
they're always telling you.
Now people has a misconception about them.
But then the whole way they sh they sell
shark week is that jaws vibe, right.
You know,
they put a ski mask on him and stuff.
They always said that they'd been
typecast and I would think with all this
progressive talk out there that
someone would speak up for them.
And then the weather channel,
they went away,
the food network where they used to
just tell you what the weather was and
they'd have some Weirdo and now it's like
all personality driven and they got to
make it sound like Jesus is going to
show up every time it fucking rains as of
my issues. Those are the things
that keep me up at night.
I would feel that about um, CNN,
headline news, not regular CNN,
CNN,
headline news used to be 30 minutes of
just news would the most middle of the
road news anchor. Right. And I'm like,
this is the way it's supposed to be.
Just a guy just telling
you nice and straight.
What's going on and now it's
personality driven. The APP,
just like you're talking about these
other gems, angry people, hot chicks,
this person, that person. Yeah. I saw one
the other night, the local La news here,
and they teased this for half an hour.
A guy got cut off on a motorcycle,
went over his handlebars and the highway,
get a couple of bumps and bruises,
but was fine. Right? But he filmed it. He
had a little camera on top of his head,
so they just kept filming the
footage on the flag itself.
May Am happens. It's this guy splitting
lanes. I mean it's legal out here,
but that's what he still in.
The guy just went,
you know the guy with to change lanes,
didn't see him.
He had went up and over and they're
like, yeah, after eight teased it,
the whole fucking like this.
This is an actual news, right,
that if you ride a motorcycle in La,
you could probably going
to go down at some point.
And he didn't even get fucking hurt. If
he died, I'd be like, wow. All right.
But it wasn't,
it was like a,
it was like the first draft
of a script where it's like,
but you got to raise the stakes.
Can he go?
Can he go over the handlebars into
the oncoming traffic? Can we get some,
can we get some of that? But the whole
thing, and it just led for 20 minutes.
They teased it and then I finally see
the footage that I already been watching.
They didn't have any more footage. And
then they interviewed him and you're like,
how do you feel? He's like, yeah,
you know I'm all right. Yeah,
I guess it was news because the guy
who hit him walked up to him said,
are you okay? And he said yes. And
then he got in the car and peeled away.
So they had his face looking at
them, you know? So I guess that,
I guess that was the news aspect,
like whether it was a hit and run,
like he looked like he didn't care enough.
The guy who hit him, he took off. Yeah,
I think he did plenty. He did. He
got out. He got out. He said you are.
The mistake he made is he peeled away.
That indicates guilt.
What he should have done was just signaled
and got back on the highway and just
be a guy. I thought it was
fine. I got out. I asked him,
I knew he had the Gopro on. I knew I was
on camera so I didn't do anything wrong.
He had a helmet on offense attorney.
I didn't have a helmet. I was fine.
I figured he'd be fine to look.
Look at the side of my car.
I was out here in la one
time watching the local news.
They said we have a breaking news.
Right,
and they had a helicopter footage of a
home who's the garage was on fire and I'm
like the only person that would possibly
give a damn about this garage being on
fire is the guy who lives in that house.
Yeah.
At least probably about
our target audience.
Nobody else would care about
that garage band on fire yet.
It was breaking news. Well, it used to
be when I lived out here in the 90s,
I remember I was just like,
this news out here is a fucking joke.
And then somewhere along the line,
national news caught up to what they
were doing out here in la. Cause when I,
I kinda stopped, I don't know
if this is probably a bad thing,
but I kind of stopped watching the
shit like at least seven years ago.
Um,
like right now I'm trying to remember
the name of the vice president and the
first one that I thought was Joe Biden,
but that was the last one. Mike Pence.
Mike Pence. Yeah. Okay. Let's see that.
I mean that's literally the backup
quarterback to the United States.
I don't know his fucking name. I
can understand not knowing the, uh,
was it the secretary of
defense? The treasurer, the uh,
well if I know those,
the coordinator of a,
cause they keep changing in the current
administration. So it is hard to keep up.
But usually when they, when they ride
for years, I can remember them all. Oh,
is that, what is that? I don't, I
don't pretend to know. All right.
So what else can we talk
about here? Anything? Anything
else you want to promote?
You get some standup dates
coming. I'm in a, I'm in a,
I get to where the actors hat
in a show called Loudermilk,
the fairer milk. Fairly brothers Peter
Fairly dumb and dumber and all that.
They've done some things. Yeah.
Well the huge, they're like, well,
the funniest fucking people ever.
Well,
Peter Fairly and a guy named Bobby
Mort created a show called louder milk.
It's about substance abuse, dark comedy.
It's on direct TV's audience network.
We just got picked up
for our third season.
I play a guy recovering from
substance abuse and uh, I,
I love it.
I never did,
never had an opportunity to do a
lot of acting and a sounds great. I,
it's just so much fun.
What is your character?
Addicted to a alcohol quaaludes the
whole thing had a big family and had a
falling out with his family and the
whole thing. And uh, but it's funny,
but serious and funny. Mostly funny.
And Ron Livingston please. The,
the main dude.
And it's like yeah.
And it's like a group discussion thing,
you know like an AA meeting.
But it's about people's, I have
direct TV. How can I see this?
It's on the audience network every
Tuesday night. Audience Network.
So is that somewhere in my thing?
If you have directv,
you should have the audience network. It's
just a channel on there. What channel?
I think two 39 to 39 500 500 Jesus Christ.
You weren't even close. Three. I
just thought you this fucking thing.
You don't know what channel?
I know it's on two 39 where I live.
Is it on 500 as well? Oh
I don't know. But uh oh on
the bus it's 500 all right.
So if you're in a house it's two 39 if
you cause the channels at the same but
direct TV, that's what I like
cause I haven't direct TV.
You go on the road and I like
going to the hotel. I already,
I know ESPN is going to be
206207208. You know, uh,
the red head channel is a 798
I get the ginger report. Let's see if
it's okay to go outside that day. Um,
Jesus Christ, looking, playing
everything close to the vest.
What else you got going on?
He had talked to you fuck fucking half
hour before I find out you weren't in the
third season of a show. That's all right.
A lot of people don't know about it.
You know it, it's an obscure, it's hard.
A lot of people haven't seen it yet,
but it's getting a lot of good buzz
and starting to get some traction.
Don't you feel like you almost have
to do three seasons of a show now,
just for the general population to know
that it exists? It's amazing to me.
I mean,
when I started in this business,
if I would have thought that I would be
on a TV show that my friends don't even
know about, and I'm not exaggerating,
I have friends who go, oh, really?
You're on a show?
And it's like my parents have never
seen the show that I'm on just for the
simple fact that I can't figure out
Netflix like they can from an age.
You just walked up, you just told the
Knob, turned on the TV for five or seven,
what do you want to watch? So they're
not going to sit there. I got to do what?
And then they got it.
They can then they got to
type in and search like they
just going to be, I'm not,
I'm not, you know, I'm not fucking
doing that. They, they are, uh,
they are old schools, so, yeah.
Um, I actually talked to somebody,
you've told this story before.
I talked to one night,
I was talking to another comedian and I
was telling her how much she liked how
much I liked her show she was
take, oh, that's great. Well,
I mean we talked for 10 minutes before
she realized the show was talking about,
had already been canceled and she thought
I was talking about a different TV
show that she was on that I had
never heard of. That's crazy.
Then I told her that I had a TV show
and she had never heard of that.
And I was like,
do you understand how fucked I could see
if we both worked at a lumber yard or
one of us did, but we're both
in this business. You're like,
you're like shooting, you know, you
don't even know what you're aiming at.
And we're both on beyond the first season.
So there is some sort of success to both
that shows that we're on and we still
have. We still haven't heard about them.
Wow. Um, anyways, where are you going?
I saw, um, I had an embarrassing
moment with the Colin Quinn.
It showed tough, tough
crowd and, uh, you know,
I saw him at a charity event or
something like that and said, hey man,
just want you to know I'm loving
you on tough crowd. And he said,
it's off the air for like
four years, you know? Oh God.
It would just feel so stupid. You know?
That's, that was the conversation.
First Conversation I've had
with Colin Quinn, I s he,
there was a movie out that he
was getting credit for writing.
Uh, oh my God, what the
fuck was it called? It was,
it was the one with Damon Waynes
and the Celtic Celtic pride. Okay.
I met him at my first comics come home
and we're literally out in front of the
crowd.
I can't believe I worked with Colin Quinn,
Denis leary and all of these guys.
The crowd's doing a standing ovation,
fucking Cam Neely standing there.
I'm like three years into the business,
I can't believe I'm a part of this. And
I see Collin and I'm like, oh my God,
that's Colin Quinn from our
remote control SNL. And I'm like,
what do I say to this
guy? So I, and I was just,
oh cause I auditioned for the
movie. So, um, I lied and said,
I saw it cause I didn't see it. I said,
hey man, I really enjoyed Celtic pride.
And he goes, I didn't write that piece
of shit. They took that away from us.
I was like, oh my God. I
said the exact wrong thing.
That's what I get for trying to kiss ass.
Uh,
but I made a mental note to never tell
somebody that I saw movie that didn't see
again. And I've broken that. You have to,
in this business, you have to do it. Uh,
speaking, uh, golf, golfing. Did
you say you were golfing with right?
Look with Colin. Is that we have we met
and you met them on a Gulf Chin thing? No,
no, no. Just at a charity show.
It was where I saw him. Jesus,
I'm so fucking burnt out. I can listen
to my goddamn guests. Well you, you,
you do you have golf. I gotta
go. I gotta go on this thing.
When is this thing gonna be here? Brian
can comes out to me. He goes, dude,
you got to go on this this three day.
It's like, it's like a spa. Right?
Yet you sober up,
you got chill out and eat nothing but
are a lot of fruits and vegetables and we
golf probiotics. We do hot
yoga, we go back, we have a,
we do hot yoga can kep aligned
again and a lot of meditating,
a lot of meditating. And it's
just so, it's so good for all,
all the fellows to get together.
We'll do that.
So when did you gotta be the fall?
When is the next one? Uh, probably May,
but uh, yeah, I'd love to
help you get involved man.
I always feel like whenever I run into
the, the few times that I go on the wagon,
I then that's when I run into you.
I, last time I boost with you is,
was in New York and that was that time.
It was, it was, it wasn't just the guys,
it was men and women.
So they pick like this fancy fucking
place in that waiter came over and you,
you ordered like a Budweiser or something
like that again, sorry. I miss here.
We didn't have it.
Uh,
we have as a divinity for the
day and you just staring at him,
waiting for him to finish. You're
like, is that a bear we miss?
And you're like, okay,
I'll have one of those
when I love you weren't even trying to be
funny. You're looking at this guy like,
is there going to be a fucking
test at the end of this? Um,
and then I saw you more recently at that,
a bar in New York and you weren't,
you weren't having cocktails at the time.
And then I felt guilty. I'm
like, I'm like six in here. No,
I every once in awhile I just, I, you
know, I shut it down for a little while.
Um, I'm going to hopefully shoot another
special coming up soon and I just don't
want to go through the whole
fuck. I gotta drop, you know,
20 pounds of pizza and beer.
I don't,
I don't feel like doing that this
time around. So I'm like, oh,
so doing it during the holiday.
So my game plan is, uh,
I'll be three weeks in on Saturday.
I'm taking one night off,
which is dangerous for me because I'm a
big binge drinker, you know what I mean?
I'm, I'm, I'm goal oriented, you know, I
see a bottom, I want to finish it right.
Then one of these,
these PAF asked people that leave sink
in the dish dishes in the sink. Sorry,
can you speak, um, now,
so I'm going to make a dinner for
my wife and then I'm going to,
we're going to drink a split,
a bottle of wine there you can in
the game plan is to immediately go,
okay, back on the wagon. However,
one of my buddies from New York
is also in town and he said, hey,
let's hang out Monday something,
well maybe Sunday and Monday
and this is what happens.
Then it becomes Sunday, Monday, Tuesday,
right. And next thing you know, you know,
I uh, I love, I think we chatted
about this in the past. I,
I, I get my work done. You know,
I work hard and what I do and I
put my nose to the grindstone,
you know what I mean? But giving me the
classic, I work hard, play hard hit.
But when you guys can see that the,
when I did more hand movement,
Trump's got to get this [inaudible]
it's like the thumb and index finger.
Everything else is lined up and then
the pinkies up like you get a little tea
cup. But when I, I'm going
to go out, you know, like,
and I'm safe about it. Car Service, the
whole thing, guys together, you know,
getting ballistic.
I like those moments or those evenings.
Um,
and it's good. No, I love
those months. You know,
when you get lit up half the year.
I hate the winter.
I don't want to remember it.
That's right. I want to be warm.
That's what hibernation
is all about. Yeah. Um,
so it's probably not a good message
for people out there, but uh,
everybody has to have that
fucking problem with it.
It's like Jesus Christ my advice. That's
my vice. Yeah, that is mine too. So I, I,
you know,
I shut it down for a couple of months
and then I slowly start back up again.
And then when I just, I just feel like
it's getting out of control of like,
I'm just, you know, I'm just living
too much of a, a, you know. Okay.
I Dunno. Just too much of
a slothful, they'll say,
because what happens is everything goes
off the rails. It's not just, okay,
I'm having too many cocktails. It's
like, I'm also eating a steak and cheese.
You want to fry side salad?
I'll take the fries. Well done.
I start doing that shit. So, um, you
know, every once in awhile I just,
I sort of dial it back and uh,
and I dial it back and I get eight
hours sleep and I, I'm just sort of a,
I like it in the morning, but
the rest of the day I'm sad. Hmm.
So you like waking up like having not
yanked the night before and go ahead.
It's found like good flat, you know, eight
hours sleep. Nobody do apologize too,
but then, you know, once after
breakfast, man, it's just
really, yeah, like the gloom.
All right, man. The next
weekend you're in. Yeah, I'm
definitely in for that. Is it?
Well, you're in Vegas, right?
Isn't going to be out there.
I don't know if I could do, I don't
think, I think I know it's a good idea.
This next one's in Florida. We do it
in a different place every, every day.
The pick of the year, it's all him. He
on the other side of the fucking country.
I'm gonna, I'm, we'll spring for a
private jet for you can, you know,
can you just book me at a
Magellan's fucking comedy club?
Every comedy club down there always seems
to be like, you know, the Captain Hook,
the barge, the by the, uh,
whatever the fuck else. The
tug boat. Tommy's my tugboat.
Tommy's down in Boca Raton. It's funny.
It's that guy from the Florida keys.
He books, uh, he books almost to Cuba.
Comedy Club, whatever. All right,
sorry. I'm sitting here reading,
trying to make dumb jokes. Um, all
right, so stand up in a way for episodes,
Netflix, Christmas Eve. Um, are you a,
you can be celebrating the holidays or
anything like that? Uh, New Year's Eve,
I'm performing finally. I get
you to fucking plug a date. What,
how long does it take me?
20 minutes. He just told me,
cause I didn't plug them on any
other thing. He said, you know,
if there's an opportunity, this is Dave,
my tour guy. Smart Guy. Yeah. He said,
you know, part of this is plugging.
He didn't say it that way. He goes,
if you can plug your New Year's eve
date, so you're a, I'm going to be here.
I am smoothly plugging my New Year's eve
day in Chicago, the Chicago theater. Ah,
New Year's Eve. That's tremendous. But
that I'm not bringing in the new year.
I'm not on stage doing the countdown.
I always, what time's your show?
Eight o'clock. It'll be over,
you know, like nine 30, nine 45.
But I want people in Chicago knowing that
like you come to the show and then you
go to a party and have fun.
I'm not going, you know.
Oh, that's such a let
down. I've done those.
And then you've got to come out and
there's like a DJ still spinning or they
want you to keep doing your fucking yeah.
Joke. No, I can't, I can't,
I can't be, I'm an MC to uh,
the countdown and they've already shut
off the bar is everybody's just standing
there sort of starting to sober up,
be like, all right everybody,
and then it's just over there.
The guy get the fuck outta here.
Yeah. Like I would in rules.
I worked this many years at this job so
I can count from 10 to zero backwards,
you know, and I've done that
so many fucking, oh my God,
all those years of doing that, I, I
don't even work new years anymore.
I work a couple extra in November
and December and then I just,
I take that night off so I'm going to
take my wife out is what I'm going to do.
There you go. She doesn't know that yet.
Cause I usually a surprise. Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
So that's what I'm
do. All right, so that's it. Everybody.
Brian, Regan, everybody. By the way, dude,
you always such a huge influence on me.
You're one of the greatest comics I've
ever seen and just decade after decade,
just still, and you
know, the upper echelon,
everybody always brings you up when they
go the best guys ever the best fucking
albums and all of that stuff. So if you're
in the Chicago area, New Year's Eve,
it's an eight o'clock show.
He's not doing the countdown.
So get some friends to hang, you know,
go to the show. And then afterwards,
pick a bar and uh, last time, uh,
stand up in a way for episodes,
Netflix,
Christmas Eve before you wrap
up, I, I have to say, I
think you're a genius.
I think you're wonderful at what you do
when you throw me a compliment that way
it means the world to me.
I love watching your craft
and how much you put into it.
You have a wonderful comedic mind.
So that compliment coming from you
means the world to me. Thank you.
And you said that just the way I wrote
it up. I love you brother. All right man.
Happy New Year and Merry Christmas
and we will golf and may I right.
All right, let's do the little bit
of advertising here. A tipsy elves.
Everyone.
Everyone needs an ugly Christmas
sweater this time of year.
Do you want the bragging
rights for the most?
Talked about sweater at the
holiday parties. Then wait
til you see tipsy elves.
Hilarious. Reimagine in a reverend new
designs. You're going to get these soon,
man.
It's almost Christmas here.
Stylish Christmas suits for the classiest
of holiday gentlemen interactive
sweaters. Oh Gee, you got there and
this climate, I don't know about that.
A beer pong corn hole,
drinking game darts.
So uncle Bob can relive his college
glory days at the family dinner.
How was that interactive?
Do I not know the definition?
That must be the third
definition in the dictionary. Uh,
interactive to participate with another
person. Definition number three,
you get down to three. It's like
a ugly Christmas sweater. Um,
anyways.
And even hilarious theme teas
and Awesome Cozy onesies for,
for women holiday dresses so you
can get down with your bad LF.
Oh Jesus, that's such a
mom SUV joke. I love it.
I catching leggings.
If you're not happy in your marriage
so you can strike a festive yoga pose,
thirsty or lounge around with a cup of
spiked eggnog and tease that sleigh and
cute,
comfy onesies.
They even sell bright and crazy ski
suits for when you're shredding some Nar
this holiday season going
west coast on that one.
You won't find some hello.
You won't find more hilariously
Austin designs anywhere else.
So be sure to order from tipsy elves
in time for your ugly Christmas sweater
party.
And right now my listeners get played
percent off@tipsyelves.com when you use my
code, Bebe Bravo, Bravo at checkout,
that's 20% off.
Anything you order on the site,
go to [inaudible] dot com and enter my
code [inaudible] at checkout to get your
20% off sitewide discount,
dollar shave club,
dollar shave club's
everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best and you
never have to go to the store.
That's because they deliver everything
you need right to your fucking door and
they keep you fully stocked on
what you use so you don't run out.
Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave Club has everything you need
to get ready and they just said this.
No matter what you're getting ready
for, they have you covered. Head to toe,
your hair, your skin, your face, you name
him. He just said, here I was working,
going back into more fucking copy.
They have a new program
where you keep your odds,
you automatically stopped up
with the products you use.
You determine what you want and when you
want and how the fuck do you do it for
once a month to once every six months?
Oh, I guess you do it. The website,
Jesus, that was like somebody
telling a bad fucking story.
Like when you get to the point plus
what they're handsome discount.
The more you buy,
the more you save,
and right now I'm not good at math,
but that doesn't make sense at right now.
Dollar Shave Club has
a bunch of status sets.
You can try for just five
bucks like their oral care kit.
After that,
the restock box ships,
regulars sized products at regular price.
Get your start a set for just $5 right
now@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr that's
dollar shave
club.com/burger for just $5 all
right, last one. Everybody hymns,
40% of men by age 40 struggle from
not being able to get and maintain an
erection because they're
thinking too much. Even if the,
even if the world's greatest actor,
even the greatest world's
greatest actor can't fake one.
Why do you guys turn to weird
solutions or do nothing?
I don't know cause you get shamed for it.
You know
what am I going to go on Oprah and talk
about that? Oh My pee pee work. Uh,
when they can turn to instead
to medicine and science for
hims.com a one stop shop for hair loss,
skincare,
sexual sexual wellness for men.
Answer a few quick questions in chat
with the doctor for confidential review
review. How does your, I I
know blood goes into your Dick.
That's gotta be like a garage door in
there. You know, like a valve, you know,
it's like a reverse varicose vein.
It's like this is the one you want.
Products are shipped
directly to your door, right?
Answer a few quick questions to chat
with a doctor for confidential review
products. Products are
shipped directly to your door.
Severe Ed isn't just an issue
for rich old guys in bathtubs.
It affects men in their thirties
and forties. Oh God bless you.
You got to get these guys
up and running again. Uh,
this is like gas monkey for your Dick.
You know, it's like a garage. Fine.
Uh, being your best means
performing your best.
It's a wreck towel
without the dysfunction.
Hard made easy sale OT say
a lot to a little friend.
Try Hymns for a month for just five bucks
will get you started for just for just
five bucks while supplies last.
See website for full details.
This would cause hundreds if you went
to the doctor or a pharmacy, go to for
hims.com/bird e d four a.
That's for hims.com f
o r a h I m s.com/burr,
um, e d capital Ed. All right,
no space between burn ed for
hims.com/burr e d.
All right,
now listen to a little bit of music and
we've got another half hour of greatest
hits from it from some Thursday
afternoon just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast from
earlier this year, five years ago.
[inaudible]
it's the holiday season.
Dooby dooby do.
Who thinks that? Sa What's
up? It's built births.
The Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 13th, 2010. How the hell are you?
I've had that fucking song in my head.
I heard it on the radio and like
the grocery store, you know,
I was growing going in
there to go buy a ham,
some glaze Jenelle gelatinous shit.
Right.
And I was in there and there was this song
on the uh,
the speakers there,
the sealant of the grocery store
that I just mentioned I was at,
if you forgot already, you
know, and I'm driving around,
I got this big fucking ham sitting in
my grocery cart and elk through the
speakers. Is this, this guy,
it sounded like it was from
maybe the fifties you know,
it's the holiday season.
Doobie Doobie do,
I can't remember if you went Doobie
Doby do or that's just how I remember
hearing it.
I'm trying to give you more lyrics cause
I got to know the name of this song
cause I want to download it.
I want to drive around La and 80
degree weather on Christmas, you know,
with this stupid look on my face listening
to that song. Other, the rest of it go.
It's the holiday season,
Doobie Doobie. Do Hey,
just take care of Katie and you cook
something like that. I can't remember.
You know how that is, you know
when the, you know the, the, uh,
what is it when they do
that thing where uh, no,
that that elevator music from the 1950s
where they actually took like sorta like
blues progression and I don't
know what they did to it.
So it's almost like still has like
date bet, but that, but there,
but that data,
maybe that's more swing and you
fucking stick it in your cut,
something like that. But
obviously it's a lot more, uh,
has a lot more family values two one,
whatever. It's the holiday season.
So please, for the love of God. So I'll
stop singing this fucking song. Somebody,
somebody let me know what the name of
that song is. Okay. And before I forget,
which, I don't know how
I would, all right. Um,
you know,
we do underrated overrated every week.
Do you guys remember that from the last
three fucking years of me doing it?
Just about every Monday I got one
for you. Underrated. The black Crowes
underrated despite the fact that
the selling out these huge venues,
this still underrated.
I went to go see him a Saturday night.
I say as they say in Boston,
it's amazing.
They actually take that word that has so
many continents and they remove all of
them like a cancer when you're going
to come on and come over Saturday,
um,
Saturday night at the palladium,
the same place where Richard Pryor
tapes live on the sunset strip.
I went down and I saw the black Crowes
play truth and salvage company opening up
and the black Crowes played
three hours people three hours,
hour and a half acoustic set.
And then they take a break like fucking
barely 12 minutes and they come back out
again. Basically after kicking the shit
out of the crowd for an hour and a half,
they take a 12 minute break,
right? Just to go back, you know,
have a cigarette and a little shot of
Gatorade and they go right back out again
and kicked the shit out of the crowd
for another hour and a half. Uh,
it's easily the best show
I've seen in like 10,
12 years. And um, I
don't, I just go see them.
They're up in San Francisco. If you're in
the area, they're playing the Fillmore,
all this, uh, all this week. And
uh, they, they were unbelievable.
And the greatest thing that I liked
about it was everything that you were
hearing was being produced by human
beings that the humans that were on the
stage as opposed to all this other
shit that you go to see. Now,
I'm not saying these people
aren't talented, but you know,
I've been flipping through the
channels like an old man, you know,
four fingers inside the fucking
waistband and my pajamas,
you know, the guy, you know,
the fucking was said married with
children just sitting there, you know,
you got the remote, the other hand
clicking through and you see like, like a,
you know,
these little pop tarts.
Even a guy like usher who
is tremendously talented,
the singing and the
dancing and all that shit.
You're hearing all of these instruments
that are not on the fucking stage.
And then you're also hearing like,
I can't say with him,
I can't remember who exactly it was,
but like you here at least it's like the
person who's singing with themselves,
they have the track going
and it's like, so I dunno,
musically, socially acceptable.
Now, like back in the day,
if you've got busted doing that, that
was like the end of your fucking career.
Everybody's just saying he's the
fucking sell out man. And that was it.
It didn't shit. So the fuck am
I trying to say? It was awesome.
Who unbelievable show. And uh,
recently I finally started,
uh,
downloading us actually some little feet.
It's a band like 20 years ago.
Guys I worked with in this warehouse
with telling me I should get into them.
And I finally got around to doing it and
downloaded their greatest hits and that
live album, uh, uh,
Christ, what's it called?
Waiting for Columbus, I believe. And uh,
they have a song on there called Wilson.
And I had listened to it and
someone was saying, Oh yeah,
the guy wrote it and that's why he got
kicked out of fucking Frank Zappa's band.
And then he made fucking,
you got with little flock story short,
the Black Crowes ended up,
uh,
they closed out their set
singing that song and it was,
it was, I was just a shit.
It was even the way they ended their set.
They didn't do the big fucking,
you know,
you know where they're just sitting there
strumming that one note and the Getapp
, Eh, is a fucking drum is sitting there
smashing all these symbols. Thanks.
A lot. Can afford you mean great,
good. I didn't even do that.
They played this really cool fucking song
and it ended on this nice just I was,
it was the shit. It was the shit.
So if you get a chance to see them,
please go see him. And uh, the
drummer of that band, Steve Gorman,
uh, has a podcast and a few
baseball fans out there to, uh,
or sports fans in general.
It's a sports podcast and a this week,
Tuesday,
I believe he's going to upload it.
Uh,
he interviewed a useless from the, uh,
the red sox. So please check that out.
And if you're not into sports,
please go see them. At the Fillmore.
I'm sure there are already sold out,
but it was, it was fucking awesome.
So there you go. There's my plug.
I am in a generous mood this week.
You know why? Because it's the
holiday season. Doobie Doobie do.
And you stick it up. Your
fucking comment. Sorry, I just,
I got a jar this loose in my head.
I'm going to figure out what
it is. So anyways, well,
well well a lot has happened since the
last time I did my podcast has an invoice
and girls,
a lot of things have happened.
Does anybody know what I'm
talking about? Just, you know,
isn't that amazing thing about
life that in six short days,
seven days,
if you're into math,
how many fucking things can happen
and just a little seven day period.
If you go back eight days and you
think of what you thought about certain
aspects of the world and how different
your opinion is a mere eight days later,
what would be a good example of that ass
shit? I don't know. Let's see. Let's,
let's just take your average
fucking Joe from eight days ago.
Like, I don't know. Let's
say like a jets fan and fan.
Eight fucking
days ago.
Huh?
What did, oh my God. I was just
looking at my fucking Mike Recorder.
I thought that whole thing. I thought,
I thought he didn't record it at died.
I taught, I taught, I taught.
He said you wanted one. Um,
I thought the thing is shut off.
Let's continue here. God Damn it.
I just fucked up my momentum.
A jets fan eight days ago.
What the fuck were they thinking?
Huh? I'm walking around now. People
eight days ago,
those motherfuckers thought that they
were going to win the Superbowl. You know,
probably taught this day we're
going to go into Foxborough
grabbed fucking Tom Brady with
his by his updated mullet.
Slap them around a little bit, put a
couple of more dimples into his chin.
That's what they thought was going
to happen eight fucking days later.
Eight days later.
Right now,
every jet fan in the country eject them,
has their green fucking head between
the knees looking at their fucking green
balls, shriveling up, pulling
up into their fucking abdomen.
All right, now here's the deal.
I'm not going to talk shit.
I talked a little bit of Shit.
I had to because of all the fucking
emails I've been getting and not just from
jet fans.
That fucking Dick from Philly.
You know who you are when you've sent
me that email. Go Bill. Give it up.
Give it up already. You sound like
a more on the jets are a fucking,
we'll have the best team in the
AFC and all that shit. All right.
I'm going to say this.
Say it real quick cause I don't
feel like I need to say anything,
but I'm a cunt so I'm going to
continue talking about this. Okay.
What did, what, what the fuck
did I tell you? What did I say?
Everything I fucking said.
I'm not even say that they can't still
pull it together and maybe win the
Superbowl.
But to refresh your memory
at the beginning of the
season when I was watching
those fucking morons on
that HBO hard knocks thing,
running their mouths, that's what I
say. Why are they talking all this shit?
They're talking as if they already won
one, two, three fucking championships.
And you remember what I said?
I said the Patriots,
the fucking Ravens, the
Steelers, the chargers,
or even the dolphins could beat this
fucking team on any given Sunday.
And Lo and behold,
within six days to fucking losses yet.
No. So that's it. I had to
give you one. I told yourself,
all right,
and here's one for you jets fans.
If you think I'm thinking that the
Patriots are fucking going to win the
Superbowl and that the defense I saw the
last two fucking weeks is their defense.
Now you're sadly mistaken.
This is why you fuckers get disappointed
every year is because you see,
you see half
a ray of sunlight and you
think, dad, that's what it is.
I still don't like our defense.
All right to fucking great weeks in a row
does not make up for the fact that you
shit the bed and let up 24 to 30
points for the first fucking 11 weeks.
So whatever the hell nine weeks,
whatever, I don't know. No,
11 weeks we were nine and two.
That's right. The first 11 weeks. So
I don't know.
Who Do you like for some reason I'm
thinking the ravens sitting there all
quietly nestled in Baltimore, right?
No one's paying attention to them.
Joe Flacco. I Dunno. I know
we beat them this year,
but I don't know if trying to beat
those guys twice a one year so I'm not,
I'm not fucking saying anything.
So there you go. That is it.
And having said that,
how fucking Hilarious,
I really felt as there's something here.
I felt really bad for the strength and
conditioning coach who stuck his knee out
and knocked that dolphin guide down.
I felt really fucking bad for that
guy because that was such a classic
spur the moment completely
out of character
move for it was just the
right set of circumstances.
Had they beat the Patriots suite before,
he wouldn't have done that shit.
And they bounce back and they were beaten.
The dolphins,
he wouldn't have done that shit.
He's never done anything like that was
just the classic that's spur of the
moment. Like it was just fuck
we got killed by the Patriots.
Fuck we're losing this game.
He's a competitive psycho cause that's
how you get to that level, right?
It would just all lined.
I'm telling you
that guy like I don't think he's a
bad guy. I really don't. It was a,
it was a piece of shit thing to do,
but you know,
there's so many fucking people in
jail because of a moment like that.
They had never committed a crime their
entire fucking life and just two major
shifts happened in their fucking life.
And then an opportunity presented itself
to think about how many times you go
down this,
you walked down the street,
you see somebody bent over tying
his shoe and your brain just goes,
why don't you just go fucking
boot him in the ass? Right?
But you don't because the other
side of you is going, wait a minute,
you can't put this guy in the ass.
What if he knows that fucking UFC
shit comes over and fucking, you know,
blows out my eye and I look like
fucking Josh Koscheck over the fucking
crosscheck, obviously his
fucking name. Right? Or what if,
what if I get arrested for assault?
What if I get sued like that voice
just beats down that other voice going,
God damn, look at those titties. Why
don't you go home and just grab them?
Just grab those titties.
They're right there. Grab them,
but you don't because you have a job.
She got a family because you're
working towards something and it's,
it's going relatively well.
You're on course.
Then what happens?
You know girlfriend dumps Hsa,
you know you lose your fucking job.
It starts to unravel and when it starts
to unravel that voice in your head,
you know I should just fucking
kicked that guy right in.
The balls become so fucking loud that
that other voice of reason is now it's way
in the back of your head. No,
you don't do that. It hurts.
You can't even hear it anymore and that's
what the fuck happened to that guy.
It was just, it was too.
I'm telling you last night,
last night, that dude
was sitting there. Yeah.
Why is this fucking thing saying
on peak and I was a too loud.
I'm trying to overcompensate for the
fact that people were saying that my,
my podcast with too quiet. Trying
to overcompensate. There we go.
Why is that light sitting there
going peak. Hello. Test one,
two, test one, two. Oh fuck you.
Okay,
so evidently the reason why it said peak
was because I had reached the memory
limit from my ls 10 all right. Deleted
some shit. I'm back. So anyways,
the fuck was I taught,
I was talking about that guy.
I guarantee you he's not a bad guy.
Last night he was sitting there talking
to his wife. He couldn't even sleep.
His wife or his girlfriend,
you know, she's sitting down
in the corner, you know,
holding her knees, sitting in the corner
going, why did you to that? And he's like,
I don't know.
I don't know why I did it.
Like Gus Grissom and the right
stuff. It was, there was a glitch.
The hatch just blue. I don't know
why. I didn't know standing there,
we were losing the fucking gay
with a guy came by it. I just,
I only stuck it out a little bit,
man. I just stuck it out a little bit.
He's, he's, he just fucking
muttering to himself.
Why did I do that?
Why the fuck? Why did I do
that? That was so fucking stuff.
There's guys in prison right now.
Why did that,
why didn't I listen to that voice?
Why I paid my taxes?
I was a cub scout.
Right?
I fucking made sandwiches for my kids,
send them off to school
and then just set one day.
My fucking neighbor. Excuse me. Carl,
can I talk to you for a second?
Um,
I know we've discussed this before.
Is there any way you could just not have
your dog relieve himself on my lawn?
And that just happens to be a fucking
shovel and you're just looking at his
mouth. Yeah. Now that you
pedal with the shovel, Bang, you
fucking do it. Then you like,
fuck, get up. Please get up. Please
get up. Did anybody see that?
Bury the shovel man.
And then you just go down that road and
you've never committed a fucking crime
and then you end up in jail.
It was just because of that one
diff circumstances were there.
I don't think that that guy's a
bad guy. I don't, it was just,
you know,
the problem is they're
being led by a crazy man.
Rex Ryan is out of his fucking mind.
Another thing that I've said
since last fucking year,
okay, that guy, I don't know
if he's bipolar or fees,
manic depressive. All right.
But I am a psycho and I can spot another
psychopharm a fucking crossed the room.
That guy is out of his mind and what the,
you know,
you gotta buy into your
coach's philosophy. Alright,
so they bought into his shit.
Talk in fucking
John Wayne Horse Shit when he was having,
they didn't realize he was
having a manic episode. You know,
all the coaches sign in that bus as
he's walking up and the depths of his
insecurity saying that, you know,
you don't even deserve to be here.
He had to so overcompensate for it. He
just, by the time he grabbed that Sharpie,
his manic episode was so
through the fucking roof.
He just starts writing on
the board. Whooo. So long
we're going to win the Superbowl.
He did that and he brought all his
players up to this manic fucking level.
And when you go that high,
you crashed that fucking low.
And that's what happened in two weeks.
This motherfucker,
the strength and conditioning
coach, no pain, no gain.
You got awarded that guy
whose dad was probably like Emilio
Estefan Fez. I have the festivals,
however the fuck you say his name, his
dad and the breakfast club, word, word,
word. I hate you. You son of
a bitch. That was his dad.
So he's got that information up
there. He's gotten rex. Ryan's manic
right in his fucking head.
And here comes this dread lodic
locked jackass running right by a
sticky nail. Stick your fucking knee
out. And he just, he went with it.
You saw him. He's trying to fight
it. Is other niece going, no, no, no.
Stay back here with me and the other
needs like, fuck that. I'm going in.
I'm fucking go in.
And he stuck it out and
that fucking dude Jesus.
Did you ever think that you could take
down a professional athlete that easily?
He looked like he fell out of a car.
He got kneed in the side of
the leg on the 40 yard line.
He didn't stop rolling until the
fuck a 12 yard line. Okay. Oh,
can you imagine that? The second he
did that shit, that poor bastard.
I bet it felt like a cold.
Like he was standing under a fucking ice
water waterfall. That even makes sense.
And then that would be like hale.
I could've just said hail whatever.
It's fucking cold.
And he stand in it
and I bet he could even feel this fun
fucking from his, his goddamn heart down.
He probably couldn't feel anything
just going like, oh my God,
what did I just do? Oh my
God, please get up. Please.
Please get up. Oh fuck. Did
anybody see that? Did Wreck?
See that? Why did I do that?
Oh my God. Oh my God. What if I
get fired? But if I get fired,
he fucking went through all of that
shit. That poor bastard. You know?
But I got to admit,
as a patriots fan,
I don't ever have to listen to the fucking
jets fans talk about cheating anymore.
Do I?
Okay.
Is The post going to have that caught
cheating with a little asterisk next to it
for the rest of the fucking season.
Are you green cuts?
Um, so there you go. Whatever. So that's,
that's this weekend football
that is this week in football.
How about those fucking Minnesota
Vikings with their inflatable roof,
you know, can you imagine if that happened
during the game? Even with helmets on,
I think somebody could die.
It's a weird thing because it's snow.
Do you think like, it's just
going to be like, you know,
getting a snow storm over with
in like a half a second. But, uh,
that was probably a good couple
of hundred pounds of snow and a,
I don't know about you guys.
I don't want a couple hundred pounds of
anything landing on me from the top of a
fucking Dome Stadium.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
That was one of the saddest moments I've
ever seen for a professional franchise.
You know, getting ready to play the New
York giants, New York football giants.
How you guys want it? You want
it? They're fucking big blue.
Fucking bring it. The 20 minutes you've
got to call back. Yeah. Listener,
you know about that football game or is
there a way we could do it on Monday?
Monday would probably work a
little bit better cause uh,
stadium collapsed and
uh, okay. We have to,
we have to get a bicycle pump and we
have to repair it. We'll duck tape. Yeah.
But uh,
okay.
I figured Detroit's in between your
city and our cities. Okay. Yeah.
You know, sort of equally
distant and uh, yeah.
And it's just a suggestion. I yeah, just
call me back. Okay. All right. Bye Bye.
Yeah.
Oh fuck. So anyways, let's, let's
get into the podcast here this week.
So that's it. I'm done
fucking talking shit. Uh,
and I got to tell you something.
I'm going to pat myself on back.
I could have been a lot
meter. I could have been a
lot meter. And you know what,
I gotta be honest with you. If I
believed in our defense a little more,
I think I would've been,
I think I would have been.
How are you doing down there in San Diego?
Paez your team slapped you around enough
this year. Jesus Christ. Whatever you do,
do not bet on the fucking charges. You
don't know who the fuck's gonna show up.
It's kill or be killed.
Rape or be raped.
That's what the fuck's
going on down in San Diego.
They're either going to win 41
nothing or lose 56 to eight.
They got a safety. That's how
they got the eight. All right.
The two field goals in a safety right is
that another works maybe then went for
a two point conversion.
I'm just trying to cover all the basis
for the fucking mathletes out there.
All right, let's move. Let's move
on here. Um, Papa, Papa, Papa,
papa bear. Oh, here's something
that somebody sent me.
They mentioned that they'd
seen Paul Mccartney, uh,
a beetle on. Uh, why don't I just
read the email? What I, let's,
who's kidding who, let's be honest. Why
don't I just attempt to read this email?
Okay. Hey Bill. I just
finished watching last night,
Saturday night live with Paul Mccartney
and I think it's time for Paul to hang
it up for good.
I feel like a bit of an
asshole for thinking it because
we're all supposed to be
in awe of him because he's a beetle.
Uh,
they let them do four songs last night
because everyone is in awe of him and
that's the problem.
No one wants to tell the 68 year old man
with the dyed brown hair and saggy man
boobs that he doesn't have the voice
for a live performance anymore.
I fear getting old and
being irrelevant too.
But I hope that when
it's my time to retire,
I can except that I'm not what I once
was and move on to something else that
better suits that stage of my life.
Paul should look to someone like Bono.
Not that I'm a big Bono Fan, but
I think he's done it right by, um,
imitating Bob Geldof's example of
rock and roll for philanthropy.
How about a pat on the back for getting
through that sentence without fucking it
up? Uh, Youtube won't draw a
stadium size crowds forever.
So Banos set, set himself up as a jet
setting friend of the world's poor.
Even if he never gave another
concert of sung another note,
he'd still have a meaningful, he'll still
have meaningful work beyond his music.
Uh, it's like you were
saying in previous podcasts,
it's good to have a side business in
case show business doesn't work out best
regards. Um, yeah. Um,
I kind of see what you're
saying a little bit, but uh,
I know a lot of people saw Paul Mccartney
last year on tour and said he was
fucking unbelievable.
And then I also think that the Beatles
right now are a victim of a backlash
because of something that they
didn't create. I think apple,
not apple is a whatever.
Itunes. That's right. Itunes.
I got real confused there because they
had apple and then Macintosh has a
fucking apple and that's all it takes
to really just send me flying down the
fucking sideline. Like that. Dreadlocked
son of a bitch. You got tripped anyways.
Um, I think iTunes has been
trying to get the Beatles catalog.
Obviously it's probably the first band
you would want to start with as far as if
you wanted to make money.
They finally got them and they
are from the baby boom generation,
Steve jobs and all those guys. So this
is, you know, this is there Jesus.
So they present the band as their Jesus
and just eventually it's just inevitable
that it's going to a
annoyed the generations after.
And not to mention,
because we weren't born when
they were putting out albums,
it's impossible for us to see how far
ahead of their fucking time they were.
You know?
And that's something I also see in comedy
where I've actually gotten emails from
people going, what's the big deal
with Richard Pryor? You know,
35 years of people ripping off his shit.
They've actually made, you
know, some of his stuff.
You know, like after 35 years
people finally caught up with them,
you know, so or like an f at
athletic things. Somebody,
somebody sent me a fucking email
this week. We talking about that a,
that running back on Cleveland.
Remember that guy I was talking
about who has the face mass?
Makes them look like the front
of a dodge ram pickup truck.
Someone was saying they thought Jim Brown
of the Cleveland browns was overrated
and that they are so sick of hearing
about this guy that if this fucking white
dude played back in that era with those
skinny people who played football,
he would have run all over.
Which uh,
a lot of people say shit like
that and it's complete bullshit
because
is if he played back then
look, if you want to stick
them in a time machine, yeah,
he would run all over those guys.
But that doesn't mean he's better.
You know what I mean? That's like,
okay, I have a big test on Tuesday, um,
the me on Friday,
we'll go back in time after I've taken
the fucking test and then I'll know all
the goddamn answers.
That's what it's like.
If you take today's athletes
and you put them back then,
which you have to do is just say,
okay,
if you take that guy and you had him
born the same year Jim Brown was born,
you know, he'd still be what he is
today because of the nutrition. The A,
the level of, of, uh,
just intelligence about sports and
what is possible at that moment,
the workout equipment in all of that.
But you know,
obviously if you take a fucking guy
you don't have,
the big flaw in that
is that kid today is not the Jim Brown
of this era or any fucking error,
you know? And if you took Jim
Brown from back in the day,
you had him born in 1980 instead of 1940.
And whenever the fuck this guy was
born and he had access to all this,
all this information about nutrition,
sports science and all that,
he would have been much
bigger than he was.
He still would have fucking dominated.
All right?
So that's one of those sports
arguments that they, that,
that people have when they're like,
they'll talk about Kobe Bryant because
they see Coby doing everything that
Jordan has already done.
They, they equate it,
therefore he's as good as Jordan and
they forget the fact that no one had ever
done that shit until Jordan Jordan
changed the game. All right?
Same thing with the fucking Beatles.
The Beatles was so fucking
far ahead of everybody,
but now it's, it's 40, almost
50 fucking years later. Yeah.
Now you're going to look
back on it and have to,
everybody's ripped him off as can be like,
dude, what the fuck was the big deal?
All right. So there's that. And then
the last thing is I'm sick of people
throwing old people out in
the fucking yard. You know,
like they're your old iPod speakers.
Eh, there's a loose wire. Fuck him.
He's out the Goddamn door. I
think it's bullshit. All right.
I like all people, even that fucking
asshole downstairs. I like them.
I respect him. And uh,
you, you, what it is,
is you look at them and you see they're
dyed hair and you see their saggy man
boobs, right? It wrinkled
up tushies. Right?
So you equate that with their level of
intelligence rather than this fucking guy
has walked this planet for
65, 75, 85 fucking years.
And uh, you know, what's that
expression? As much as things change,
they stay the same stitch in time
saves now with other fucking him.
I remember expressions,
whatever, you know,
this guy has seen everything
that you're about ready to see.
He's already seen it. Okay? He didn't
have a fucking iPod. Who gives a fuck?
All right. A cunt is
still a cunt. All right?
Some things don't fucking change.
And this guy has this whole
wealth of knowledge. They,
here's a guy's been playing live gigs for
50 something fucking years. All right?
He can still physically play.
Why wouldn't you want to go see him,
you know, with all his fucking
experience, you know? Yeah. I mean,
I could see if he was
jumping off the piano,
trying to do splits and
touches fucking toes.
And then he came down and blew out his
knee and they had to give him the fucking,
a Geritol rub right on is blown out
knee then. Yeah. You know what I mean?
But like I don't like that whole fucking,
it's like,
it's like a corporate mentality. Why
your skin's wrinkled up. We have no you,
we don't like looking at you beat it.
I Dunno.
I'd still go pay to see the rolling
stones. I would. Why wouldn't you?
Why the fuck when those got red.
Those guys give me hope that I can sit
there and drag my ass out on a fucking
stage. 80 years old. What's
up with Medicaid, you know,
out on a cruise ship.
But I do understand what you're saying
because I definitely want to, uh,
if I'm on stage
in my sixties and seventies and sixties
is fine cause I'm still going to be
fucking annoyed and want to be out there.
But in my seventies,
if I'm still on fucking stage,
I want it to be because uh,
because I had not because I need the
money because I want to be out there.
All right. I remember Keith, Richard's
saying like, someone was like,
when are you guys going to hang it
up? He's like, never, I'm a musician.
This is what I do. I will do this
in front of two people or 200,000.
It's what the fuck I do. You want
me to put down my guitar? You know,
he has a great line in his book where
he talks about how much he loves guitar.
I don't know if I said this
last week, Keith, which is,
has this book called life.
It's the fucking shit.
And um,
he talks about how he loves
guitars so much that to this day,
like he opens a guitar case
and just the smell of a guitar,
he wants to crawl in there
and close the lid. All right?
So if you ask this guy to
stop going up playing live,
you might as well put a bullet in his
brain. You're killing the man. Okay.
So having said that,
let Paul Mccartney do is fucking thing.
Has any been through enough?
I mean that guy truly found the
love of his life. All right,
you fucking dies then.
He's in a bad place.
Like the fucking jets strength coach.
He goes out,
he married some gold digging
whore with one leg, you know,
which was the classic
fucking misdirection.
Cause I bet the back of his
head, he kept going, you know,
I think she's a fucking gold digger.
And then the other place like dad,
she only has one leg man.
Stop being so mean. Right?
And then he just gave
into that and they go,
hey, you think if you tried to
trip her, you stuck your knee out?
Like maybe there was a possibility that
she's athletic enough that her fake leg
would just fall off and she would just
be able to continue hopping down the
sidelines and make a play. Granted,
she'd get a penalty if she,
if she ran out of bounds on her own.
You know,
that's a question for you this week.
If that fucking gold dig in more
with the one leg. If she ran down,
she had a fucking dolphins uniform on,
right?
She went to the islands and got her hair
braided by some dude in Jamaica. Right.
And she comes flying down the sideline.
If you stuck your knee out,
hit her fake knee. Right.
Knocked her fucking leg off.
Why am I repeating what you just heard?
Everything I just said.
Do you think that she would
have the ability running
full speed? All right, we'll,
we'll uh, we'll adjust it a little bit.
You tell her you're going to do it.
You didn't really have legs going to
fucking pop off. Now the fake one.
Jesus Christ. We think I'm an asshole,
but just shut up. You're dumb whore.
All right,
I'm going to fucking not shut up.
I'm going to knock your fake
fucking leg off, sweetheart.
When you're running full speed, if
you can keep your balance. All right,
we'll give you some shiny shit.
You're gold digging whores.
Do you think she could do it?
That is my question for you.
During the holiday season.
Doobie Doobie do and we knock
off your fake leg. You can't.
Um, all right, what else do we got here?
You guys want some youtube
videos for the week? MMM. Okay.
Once again is great as the
black Crowes were. Let's,
let's talk about some fucking
music that, um, I respect,
but uh, I, I have to shut
it off every time I hear it.
And that is basically the
melancholy singer songwriter.
Put a gun in your mouth
early to mid 70 shit.
You know, did I talk about this last
week? I can't remember. Like Carol King
[inaudible]
hey baby [inaudible] is too.
They
[inaudible] [inaudible] has
died and fucking kill yourself.
View douchebag. [inaudible] fuck it
goes that song. James Taylor, I see.
He found,
I've seen rain.
My fucking friend died in a plane crash
and I always thought that I'd see you
once again, Carly Simon. That's the way.
That's the way I've always heard it
should be. I'm telling you right now,
don't ever listen to that song on a rainy
fucking day. If you put that song in,
you have a 40% chance of doing
something really harmful to yourself.
Joan Baez, diamonds, and rust.
You know, and I have the song. If you
ever one of those songs ever comes on,
you're in a car and you don't have
control of the radio and you just feel
yourself getting dragged
down this bottomless pit.
I have the song that is basically like
that in adrenaline injection to the
heart, like in pulp fiction. Just
put on Huey Lewis hip to be square.
All right?
I can't take 100% credit for that.
Me and a young Joe Derosa.
All right.
The teen idols sensation of the opiate
Anthony Program we're taught was,
was actually a segment that we'd
love to do on the uninformed shelf
that we do once every nine
years. At this point, uh,
we were talking about how it's impossible
to be depressed if you listen to Huey
Lewis and the news put
on hip to be square.
I challenge you not to fucking
get a smile on your face.
It's like trying to hold off a yawn. You
know, you can't do it. It's impossible.
So, uh, I don't know. I don't need a
why I'm bringing this shit up, but like,
I don't know what it is about that music.
I respect it once again.
Get back to the black Crowes thing cause
it's actually human beings producing
all the sounds that you're
hearing. All right. But uh, yeah,
you know Jesus Christ already.
Do those people have any happy songs?
Who's another one? Oh, that that
fucking girl sings in the false set of,
with a weird eyes.
Joni Mitchell
singing about a paved, paved
the parking lot, pay paradise,
turned it into a parking lot. You
don't know what you got till it's gone.
I'll write Joanie.
I got it last week was better.
Jesus Christ. You fucking, you know,
I don't know. I did, I it, was there any,
was there a point that was made there?
Other than the fact that
I can't sing? Um, oh,
here's a music question for this week.
As you guys also know other than playing
drums, I a I fuck around and guitar.
Um,
and uh,
I recently bought ACDC flick of
the switch, another underrated,
which I know I did last week.
Underrated ACDC flick of the switch.
I just want to know what
tuning of those people in are.
They tuned down like half a step because
it's like I listened to the album,
I shut it off.
Then I go and I go to figure it out.
Let's take the first song for you.
Guitar players out there. Rising power.
All right. He's doing a pull
off down to a B court. Right?
But are they tuned down like half a step?
Because last night I'm sitting there in
my jam jams and I got my guitar that I
can't even fucking play.
And I'm like, you know what,
I'm gonna have a little geek moment
by myself that nobody can see.
I'm going to put on my just
fucking record. I'm going
to play along to this song.
Cause I figured it out the Malcolm
part and it sounded like shit.
And I tried tune it down half assed and
I just could not fucking figure it out.
And beyond the fact that I suck,
can somebody help me out?
What are they doing there?
I know it's not a drop d
drop d tuning.
Cause I know what that sounds like.
That sounds like Satan is
your bitch and you got,
you got some errands for for it to run.
I know what that sounds like.
And I challenged somebody to come
up with a riff in drop d tuning.
That doesn't fucking rock. It's just,
it's just, it's the shit. Right?
But does that tune down half a step that
I, I can't fucking get. Come on man.
You heard how I sing?
Help me out here.
Help me out or I'm gonna fucking sing
for the rest of this podcast. All right.
It's [inaudible] season. All right.
Wait, let's, let's continue on here.
Um, oh, I got my, uh, I tell you
somebody rear ended my Prius.
You know what I mean?
Which really is like fucking boot in
eight year old in the ass when you really
think about it.
Um,
and got it just hard enough where I
couldn't walk away and be like, Eh,
don't worry about it. You
know, my hatchback wasn't
quite closing correctly. Um,
you know what I mean?
Wasn't quite,
didn't quite work on the hatchback area.
Kind of like a girl with a big booty.
You know what I mean? There's always
a little bit of butt crack coming out.
Who's got a tug?
You know,
that's how you can judge if
you see a girl with a nice ass,
whether or not she's a whore or not.
If she's constantly trying to adjust
their genes and pull them up, sir,
ass crack isn't coming out of the back
of her pants. Uh, that's a good girl.
That's when you can take home to mom.
Just make sure she wears a dress.
But if she's just standing there with
like an inch and a half coming out and she
doesn't give a fuck, I can't even
say that she's a fucking whore,
but either that or she's
just accepted who she is.
And for some reason that they don't make
jeans for girls like that. All right.
That's one of those references that
it just was such a visual to me that I
completely forgot what the fuck I
was talking about. Let's go back.
We were talking about
talking about guitar.
Who gives a fuck? Oh, was
talking about my car. So anyway,
so I'm getting it fixed this week.
And uh,
so I went down to the rental
car place and it was a usual,
I go down there and I asked for a
fucking, uh, uh, an economy car.
You know, I don't give a shit. I really
have no pride when it comes to cars,
even though I fucking love him.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm just so into not having debt
that I, I'm, I'm, I'm a little miser,
so I get this a con I go down and they go,
well,
the economy car isn't quite ready.
We could give me a free upgrade
to this four door fucking pickup.
And uh,
then it just became my,
you don't even get outweighs my miserly
ways is, uh, I don't like waiting.
I refuse to wait. So I go,
yeah, fuck it. I'll take it.
And then immediately my girl was
just like, why did she get that?
I can't try that. It's so
big. What am I gonna do?
I'm like, we only got until Monday.
Fucking relax. Plus we got to get
the Christmas tree this weekend. All
right, well, you know, Dasher red area,
Vic said
Ledson if you want,
how I did that, there was not some
Phil Spector Shit that's called just,
you just spin it around three 60 away
from your mouth and you just keep talking,
cause back around you like that.
It's a new recording
process I just invented. Um,
so anyways, uh, I go, yeah, we
got to go get the Christmas tree.
So for the last two years, I have to
admit something to you people. All right.
I have been going down to get these
fucking Christmas trees and I've been
getting the traditional Christmas tree
and we all know what it looks like.
All right. It looks like someone on
the biggest loser about four weeks in.
That's what a Christmas tree
spots about that full, you know?
But there's these other Christmas trees
that I noticed, not the scrawny ones,
but they are minimalist Christmas trees
where you can see the entire trunk and
it's like they still have the branches,
but there it's very like symmetrical.
It looks fucking cool as hell.
Clean look and Christmas tree, right?
It looks like one of those trees.
And like the doctor Seuss books,
you know?
So I go, you know what? Fuck this.
I'm going to get something different.
I liked this tree.
It looks fucking cool.
I think the ornaments are going to hang
off it much better as if you know when
you get one of those full trees,
you know this. Yeah. It's just,
it's a fucking pain in the ass. And
then the end of the end of the Goddamn,
you know,
Christmas season,
if you're not a dick and you just don't
throw it out the side of your car,
like a fucking some,
you know,
some piece of degenerate gambler
that owed you money. I said,
have it by Tuesday and then you just
throw it out the fucking car, right?
If you actually do it the right
way and you just saw it up,
it's a pain in the ass and makes it
unbelievable mess this thing, you know,
it's like, it's like you have a walk into
like, uh, like when I'm out with, with a,
with Nia and we'd go out to one of
her, uh, her clothing stores and um,
if it's like a corporate place,
the place is just jam packed with Shit.
But if it's like a privately owned,
they go out and they buy
these individual pieces.
They'll buy a couple of sizes
of each things that they
like. And you go in there,
you pray to God that they
have your size and it's,
and you go in and it's very minimalist.
That's the sort of Christmas tree
that I bought and uh, you know,
knee as a fashion Easter.
So I thought she would like it.
So I bring this Christmas tree in
and the second she looks at it,
cause I think she's going to
be like, you know, like I live,
she just have like techno music on like
I'm so far into the fucking future here.
The second she looks at
it all my confidence just
drains out the bottom of my
shoes. And I go, yeah, this is the
Christmas tree. And she goes, oh yeah,
because where's the rest of it? And
I'm like, no, no, that's the style.
That's the style it's supposed to
look like that. I go, doesn't it cool?
I mean it looks like one of those trees
and Dr Seuss, she goes, yeah, she goes,
I think it looks more like that.
That Christmas tree in
that Charlie Brown cartoon
snow,
I feel like an asshole.
So because I love the verbal abuse that
you guys give me every fucking week.
I'm actually going to be dumb enough
to send a picture of my Christmas tree.
Now granted it's naked. It's
not all dressed up. It's not
all dolled up. All right?
It's like Charlie's thrawn in that
stupid movie monster that rather than
chastising her for being a murderous cont,
they actually made a movie that said,
maybe guys outta look at themselves and
treat bitches a little bit better before
they go and start killing
you after a blow job.
It wasn't that the message in
the move SMS a gy got so anyways,
it doesn't have any makeup on,
which I think should automatically
give it a golden globe for being that
courageous. It was so brave. It
was such a brave performance.
I'm just take a look at the Christmas
tree. Tell me what you think.
I think it looks fucking Badass.
I love it.
I fucking love it. And uh,
I stand by it. You know,
I'm breaking a little tradition here. So,
uh, go on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
Take a look at my Christmas tree.
We'll have a whole section where you can
leave your goddamn comments about what
a moron you think I am. Um,
or maybe you actually like.
Um, and along with that, you can
also look at these youtube videos,
the youtube videos of the weak people.
I just felt like I should have had a
theme, some theme music right there.
At some point,
at some point,
I'm going to have a make enough
money in this fucking business.
I'm going to make a little studio and
I'm going to have all those little sound
effects, like a real radio show like
Anthi on opiate, Anthony, you know,
he's got all those little buttons he
pushes and ops got all his little buttons
that they push, you know, those
button pushing son of a bitches.
I want to be one, two, I have
dreams. Um, and when I do,
I'll have a little fucking theme
music here. Uh, but until then,
you'll just sit there and listen
to the awful silence. All right.
Youtube videos of the week that you
can watch on the MLM, podcast.com,
the official, uh, Fan Webpage,
whatever the fuck you call it of the
Monday morning podcast. All right,
youtube video. Uh, this is
one of my favorite ones. Uh,
if people puking makes you sick,
please don't watch this. But, uh,
you know,
the great thing of watching a videotape
of somebody puking is you don't have to
smell it. So you can just
enjoy the hilarity that it is.
You know what I mean? It's like
that shit that people, they, they,
the vaporizer with weed, you know,
where it gets rid of everything,
all the toxins that just keeps the
shit that gets you high. This is,
this is the vaporizer version
of watching somebody puke.
Watch this video is this,
this is such, this video
literally made me cry. Laughing.
Uh, epic beer pong puke. Um, it's just,
it's got it off the,
the, the volume of Puke,
the noises kids making when he's puking
and then the fucking good natured
attitude that this dude has.
He actually,
he has poise while puking.
I think Mark Sanchez could learn a
little something about this. You know,
a little poison under fire by the way.
One of their offensive lineman got hurt.
Now Watch your run for his fucking life.
All right.
This game management son of a bitch.
Oh,
you're so right about those
mother fuckers. All right. Um,
all right. Youtube video. Another one.
Uh, this one is just so fucking creepy.
Um, I love this. I want to go
on a date with this woman. Uh,
it's called the best model in the world
and I'm sure a lot of you guys have
already seen this and I'm sure
tosh 0.0 is already put up. Uh,
but it's the best model in the world hand
model and is this woman talking about
being a hand model? And for a
lot of people it's what she says,
but for me it's the way she
just keeps stroking her hands.
I don't know what she's doing,
but it is so fucking creepy.
I want to go on a date with her.
I want to take her out to dinner,
have her sitting across from me as I
tell her about how many brothers and
sisters I have and my hopes and dreams
in life as she sits there nodding,
just stroking her hands. And that it
would just, it would really, you know,
I don't know,
call me a fucking psycho,
but I would really love to just have that
experience. It's on my bucket list. Um,
ah. Did I spell this right? The next
one is Cammy secret parody, boob apron.
You know that thing,
that commercial they have out there where
a women with the big titties and then
all their boobs are always
fallen out of their shirt,
but they don't like wearing something
underneath it to alleviate the problems.
So they created this little napkin
that hooks onto your bra straps. Uh,
first of all, let's pause and just say
how fucking brilliant an idea that is. Um,
as far as just making $1 million,
you know,
this checks out there who just
have, you know, efficient boobs.
It's trying to think of a nice
way of saying small boobs, um, um,
comparable, capable titties, right.
This still going to buy them just because
I like having different colors and
sometimes I don't want to wear a shirt.
And then those other girls who lie to
themselves about how big their boobs are
and for some reason they've,
they buy a D Cup Bra, you know,
when they got BEACOPP titties,
I don't know why they do that.
Kind of like the guy who goes in and
buys the magnum condom and then it slips
off and he becomes a fucking father for
the ninth time. Uh, yeah, just watch that.
It's a parody of that. And um, this
next one, all I have is a website,
but my, uh, my web guys definitely
going to have it up. Uh,
if you want to watch a video of somebody
who's about ready to get arrested by
the FBI, watch this video.
This guy took one of those, uh,
um,
you know,
as those nerds who rather than going
out and getting a pilot license,
they go down to an open field
and they just fly like a,
a fake playing around a
model airplane motorized.
There it is motorized playing around.
This guy put a camera on it and he
flew around the New York City skyline.
Oh yeah. I'm sure this guy isn't
going to get in trouble at all these,
they had the brains to
blur out their faces,
but the dude is talking on the video.
You can hear his voice.
They're going to get caught.
Some Kuntz gonna recognize his voice that
he went to high school with. You know,
by the way, people, if
you do something illegal,
if you're going to be dumb
enough to videotape it,
don't put it on fucking youtube and of
all the fucking cities to do it too.
I mean it's definitely,
the footage is fucking cool,
but this guy buzzes the statue of Liberty
with this model fucking airplane and
considering the military has those drones
that can fly around and just vaporize
people, it's probably not a good idea
to have one of those flying around.
I'm going to go out on a limb, so
I'll look for that news. Everybody,
these guys getting arrested in the
next couple of weeks. Um, okay.
We also have the youtube video of the uh,
the jets strength coach
tripping the Dolphin.
If you just want to watch that and just
watch that with my psycho analysis.
Is that all right? My psycho
psycho analysis of that guy? Uh,
is that it? I think that's it. Those
are the youtube videos of the week.
And what are we up to here
at this point? Ah, by Golly,
will you look at that 53 fucking
minutes? Um, I know what I need to do.
I need the height. My last
stand up Gig, my last official,
one of the official one of the year.
I am going to be at the Improv
out here in Bray, California.
Beginning this Thursday and I'm can
conclude on Sunday and it's going to be a,
what's that? December
16th, 17th, 18th and 19th.
Um, and I gotta tell you my new hour
is, I'm really happy with where it's at.
A sign. I figured something
out somewhere during Seattle,
right through the cobs Gig in San
Francisco and I'm really excited,
really excited to go out
there. So, um, you know,
come on out and see me. How
about some Latino people? Ah,
trying to break into this market
out here. Like I, I don't,
I don't know how to get in
touch with you guys. You know,
I started doing that Rosetta Stone
Shit. I fucking, I quit it. You know,
I really want to learn how to speak
Spanish and I'm realizing that if it did a
little bit of Rosetta stone and I
just had somebody who spoke Spanish or
Mexican, whatever the fuck it is, you skip
call it. Not trying to offend anybody.
I want to know how to do it. I
think it's fucking, I don't know,
it's a cool language.
I want to learn how to say it.
Then I can talk to some Spanish
women. Who the fuck am I kid? Alright,
so that's it. I'm going to be there this
Thursday, Friday, Saturday, and Sunday.
All right? If he, if he can't
make it there and you're
in the San Francisco area,
I'm telling you, go see the black
rose. Go see them because, uh,
I think they're going to take a little
bit of a break after this tour from what
I've heard. Uh, you know,
it just fits into my whole,
don't go to the automated checkouts.
Don't go to see these fucking
auto tune jackasses. Go,
go see the real fucking deal. All
right there. I'm done with that shit.
And with that, is that the podcast for
this week? I'm coming up a little short.
All of a sudden, am I running out of gas?
You know what it is, is I'm, I'm in a,
I'm in my vacation mode already
and I'm in a silly fucking mood.
I got my Christmas tree and I'm going
to be singing out those fucking holiday
songs this weekend on stage
or just society that just
for the podcast listeners,
and I'm not even going to
explain why I'm doing it.
I'll be telling Joe Ganim this guy
can go fuck himself and style today.
Cs Ed Beagle Bay though. Um,
all right. Who's kidding?
Who am I going to keep
repeating that fucking joke?
Is that what I'm going to do,
Bill?
Are you pulling the Paul Mccartney right
now and you don't know when to get off
stage according to that one
fucking listener? I think I am.
Did I have any underrated,
overrated, underrated?
A four door pickup truck
like I rented this week,
couldn't believe how convenient was
I went to go see the black crows.
I put me in for other
adults in that thing.
We went to go see him and
then the next day I got a,
I got a fucking a Christmas tree
in the back, standing upright.
You know, it's funny when I put it in
the truck, uh, these three people walk,
we're walking down the street. One of them
was some Mexican dude, any in Spanish.
He said something and started laughing
and I was convinced he was laughing at my
tree.
You know another reason why I would
have loved to gotten through the Rosetta
stone so I could've said in Spanish,
um,
actually it's not the Charlie
Brown tree or right Hector,
it's supposed to look like that.
Thank you. Very classy is very much
just a freak them out. You know
what I mean? Cause you know,
nobody thinks a white
do can speak Spanish.
Like how many times did George Bush catch
somebody's saying something fucked up
as he sat there in his fucking white
elite fucking brown penny loafers with no
socks in his Pete Carroll coach and pants,
right.
Jesus Christ to the Seahawks,
get their fucking asses kicked this
week or what I went to and to this week,
everybody, I finally went
500. I got something for,
for gamblers out here that I know
you're all going to agree with.
All right. And, uh, oh
before I say, you know,
one of the reasons why I didn't do an
extra podcast because a lot of people were
asking me how come right
after the jets game,
you didn't do a podcast making fun
of the jets. That's because I didn't,
I didn't believe in our defense and I
thought we had a really good chance of not
, uh, you know, of losing that game by a
couple of points just because you know,
when you let a 24 to 30
points, that's what, you know,
that's definitely a possibility.
And a,
I just thought it would have
been bullshit if I came. Yeah.
You know what the fuck you,
you fucking lost.
That's also why I kind of
took it easy on you this week,
which you probably don't think I did,
but hey,
I did defend your fucking strength
and conditioning coach, didn't I will.
All right then why don't I just talk
about that and I can't remember what I was
talking about.
Here's one for the gamblers out there.
So I took the eagles last night.
All right.
Given three and a half against
the cowboys. Had they won,
I would have gone three and one which
I desperately needed instead, you know,
and they drive down,
write down the fucking field,
all right there down by three points and
they can kick a field goal and win the
bet. But because it doesn't matter,
they just want to win the game.
They take a knee and they
run out the fucking clock.
And this is a rule that I think
the NFL should do, you know,
subtly without letting the public now
because they really can't line up with
gamblers in anything.
I really think that is in a sign of
solidarity for the regular Joe out there.
We actually had the balls to put money.
So believed in your fucking team.
If you put money on your fucking team
and you have a chance to cover the spread
and the final fucking second, she
should. God Damn it. You should do it.
Andy Reid kicked a field
goal. You're fucking asshole.
Oh, I needed three in one.
I needed that. So fucking
bad. Now I'm two with two.
I can't pick a game to save
my fucking life. You know,
it was funny was I took Tampa this week,
Tampa and Atlanta had
been my goto teams and I,
for some reason Carolina has been
a little Jekyll and Hyde, so I,
the game scared me. It's a divisional
game. I just didn't fucking like it.
I stayed away and I went with the ramps
because the saints have been Jekyll and
Hyde and I wasn't buying into
this. Oh, here they come,
shit that they've been doing the last
couple of weeks at Sam Bradford has been
shown that he can play at that level.
Yeah,
hundred percent wrong on that game and
I can tell you this right now to save
yourself a fucking ulcer.
When the team,
you bet on throws a pick six I don't
give a fuck if it's in the first quarter.
Shut the game off. It's over the
goddamn 14 point. Turn around.
All right, whatever. I Bitch
Moan and complain enough.
What? Common right up on an hour. I
think that's a good, that's a good,
that's a good number, isn't it?
That's it. God bless all of you.
I hope you enjoyed the podcast this week.
Get out there and go do your quads at
Christmas or a Hanukkah is it over yet?
I saw a couple of people driving around
with Menorahs on top of the car is not
even bullshitting. Um, I thought only
idiots did that with Christmas trees. Uh,
they mocking the idiocy of Christians
or they like, we can be dumb to,
you know,
like how women do,
how come only you guys get to box and
have brain damage. We want to do it too.
You know,
why are women so convinced that
everything guys do is so fucking worthy of
getting involved in too?
You know, we're dumb.
Just sit back and think a minute.
I want to join the workforce rather than
sitting around hanging out with cute
little kids. I know it's a job.
What the Fuck's wrong with you?
Wouldn't that be awesome as a guy?
Just think about that right now.
If the roles were reversed,
you know,
and you had the option of just marrying
some rich broad who just go out there
and just take care of you and all you
gotta do is just keep the house clean and
make a meatloaf a couple times
a week you can just tap out.
Yeah. You know, I'm not
saying you have to do that,
but there's a lot of us out there who
would, yeah, I do that for a couple.
I think I'll be in fucking stay
at home dad for a couple of,
and just chill the fuck out.
Right.
Getting incredible shape. So sick. All
those broads out there talk. Well, I get,
I understand what they're out of shape
because they had to carry the baby.
But if you're a guy, there's no fucking
reason why you can't be in shape.
You didn't have to carry that kid around.
You know,
you got all day long to work out.
Oh my God. There'll be the shit. I
know what you think of. Oh, these kids,
they never fucking go
to sleep. Yeah, they do.
They take a nap every fucking you can
nap with them. You can figure out a time,
you can go out and go buy all kinds of
healthy food and then just chill out.
I would get the fucking NFL package.
I would just whined to my rich wife,
just be a, come on guys, I won.
Yay. Would you, you do like the,
you know they do the little girl thing
when they want something. Oh I just drive.
I just draw. Maybe you'd buy it for
me. I do that with the NFL package.
Right. Do you know, just make it a little
easier when the kids are screaming,
all right, and I would fucking
tape every goddamn game.
It would be my mission every week that
I was going to watch all 16 NFL Games or
whatever the fuck they have. Cup
people have by weeks, 14 games,
whatever the fuck it is.
And I would sit there like a fucking
defensive coordinator who was waiting for
the phone to ring, you know, and what's
going to get picked up or some shit.
And I would just, I would watch all
of those games and I would get a gate,
I get a,
a padded fucking play room where the
kids couldn't hurt themselves and I just
fucking get a gate where they couldn't
get out and I just stick them in there
all day and uh,
play amongst yourselves and that I would
just watch all these games and every
once in awhile I would just throw food
in there. Like they were like, you know,
animals at the zoo.
Yeah.
You know,
rather than make it three sandwiches,
I make one big one and I just throw it
in the middle and then just film it like
the discovery channel, you know,
with the pecking order, like the,
the most dominant male
lion gets to eat first,
then all the other ones sitting
there, you know, Growlin and shit.
Waiting to see when the, when the
biggest one is full, when they can go in.
I think I'd like that. Uh, all right,
that's it. That's a podcast for this week.
Please help me out.
I want to know about that one legged
gold dig and whore running down the
sideline.
If she could keep going.
I want to know what tuning ACDC is
using on the flick of the switch album,
particularly. Uh, uh Oh,
it houses on fire and
rising power. And, um,
it'll be funny if it's standard
tuning my ears just that bad. And, uh,
what's the last thing?
Was there anything else?
I know I fucking asked you something else.
I don't fucking know what. All right,
that's the podcast for this week. Have
a great week. Hope you enjoyed it and go
[inaudible]
Yay.